turning to Tulsa Oklahoma the city
expects a hundred thousand people this
weekend for president Trump's campaign
rally and the city's Juneteenth
celebration the state is activating up
to 250 National Guard troops to help
with security while local officials
worry about all those people spreading
the coronavirus Omar Villafranca is in
Tulsa outside the arena where the
president will hold his first rally in
more than three months
Omar there is quite a big crowd
gathering in that city isn't there good
morning there is a matter of fact the
crowd is behind me and they're starting
to stack up it's a several dozen people
that are here and they're starting to
camp out and that's a concern because
here in Tulsa County they've seen a
spike in cases with people in the age
group of 18 to 34 obviously that's a big
concern and of course with the
president's rally and the counter
protests and June team celebrations this
weekend they're expecting a lot of
people in that age group now Oklahoma is
one of 18 states that has seen an
increase in cases in nearby Texas
hospitalizations are up 85 percent since
Memorial Day arizona's seven-day average
rate of positive test is over 17 percent
and that's nearly four times the
national average
the Trump campaign is requiring ticket
holders to sign a waiver saying they
will not sue if they contract the corona
virus and before they go into the BOK
Center behind me they're gonna have
their temperature taken they're gonna be
given sanitizer and a mask but it's not
mandatory to wear that mask inside Tony
all right Omar thank you very much